now there is good news here though
because as the left puts on this
performance
about the lack of politics the
non-partisan people the people who are
independent
for the actual undecided voters trump is
doing
great for the actual undecided voters
issue by issue everything stacks against
joe biden new study was released last
week
that showed 66 to 70 percent
of likely voters in five battleground
states support
school choice publicly funded school
choice
school choice is a huge winning issue
for republicans we should talk about it
all the time
because joe biden totally opposes it
donald trump
totally supports this is from the
manhattan institute which commissioned
this survey
added it on to a poll from rasmussen
this was conducted in pennsylvania ohio
wisconsin michigan
north carolina all these battleground
states joe biden
has a very very negative view
of school choice and so the point is
if i'm president betsy devos's whole
notion from charter schools to this are
gone
all gone i actually asked secretary
devos about this when she came on the
verdict podcast
with um with me and senator cruz you can
check out that episode as well
now why are democrats doing this it's so
unpopular
they're doing this because they're in
bed with the teachers unions the
teachers unions
are part of their constituency they in
some in some parts own
the democratic party so they're not
allowed to support school choice even
though seventy percent of people support
trump and the republicans should run
hard on this there's another big issue
too
there's another big issue that the
republicans and trump in particular ran
on in 2016.
and he hasn't talked about it as much in
2020 but it's a huge
winning issue and the democrats are
completely
wrong on it it is not working at all it
does involve security
it does involve protection the left
they want to pretend that people are on
their side with this issue but they're
not that issue is
immigration washington post just comes
out they say trump's refugee ceiling
is bad for everyone but bigots
here we go deplorable irredeemable dregs
of society that's what you are
if you oppose taking in more and more
immigrants into this country now
what president trump has said is that
he's going to reduce the number of
immigrants who come into the country not
by a lot
just by very little he said as a matter
of
the refugee policy in the new fiscal
year
15 000 refugees will come into the
country 15 000 seems pretty nice
now before that under the obama
administration you saw
a cap at about 96 000 but why would we
be taking in all of these refugees
when there has been relative peace all
around the globe
we've been pulling out of these wars one
of the arguments for taking in refugees
is look we're involved in these wars
and because of that we have a
responsibility these local populations
so we're going to take them in whether
or not you agree with that
argument that was the argument now we're
saying okay
we're still going to take in 15 000
we're just not going to take in
i don't know 100 000. america takes in
more immigrants
legal as well as illegal than any
country on earth
by a long shot we're talking about like
two million per year
the last 60 years has been the largest
migration
from one place to another or from
multiple places to another
in the history of civilization
we've never seen a larger migration than
we have into the united states
over the past 60 years and people
justifiably
think maybe that's a little bit too much
not because we don't like people around
the world but just because
it's very difficult to assimilate that
many people we have the largest foreign
born percentage of the population we've
had since
the 1890s and at this time
we're being told we have to discourage
assimilation
well if you don't have a common culture
if you don't have a common language
if you don't have common practices then
you don't have a country
right then you don't have a common
country and that's what we're seeing
coming apart at the seams it's not
really the immigrant's fault necessarily
it's the the policies and the people who
are
using immigration policy to try to
further weaken the country
because they think the country is rotten
and evil and no good such as the people
who support for instance the
1619 project view of america or the
people who believe that america is
hopelessly bigoted or the people who
want to destroy our system of law and
order
any of those people most americans
though
want to reduce immigration levels there
was a survey came out a couple years ago
that showed that americans want to
reduce immigration
dramatically by 60 percent or so
and this is a majority of americans who
want to do it not just republicans
it cuts into democrats as well that's a
big winner
we were told when trump came down that
escalator in 2015 remember we were told
this guy there's no way this guy's going
to win he just said that ill
that illegal immigration might not be a
great thing
he called illegal immigrants criminals
and rapists and murderers
there's no way he's never going to win a
hispanic vote and
he's certainly never going to win and
what was so funny is you had a lot of
hispanic voters saying like yep yeah
that's true
those drug cartels man they're pretty
bad they cross the border a whole lot we
don't like them we're very against them
of course because people all agree with
it not all of them but most people agree
with this
but political correctness means they're
not allowed to say it out loud so that
when someone comes in
such as a trump and says what they're
thinking they might criticize him in
public
but they will vote for him that's a
great issue for republicans
school choice abortion both going in our
favor or school choice rather
immigration both going in our favor
abortion actually though is as well
and joe biden has now gone completely
out in the open on abortion
there used to be a view among the
allegedly devout catholics in this
country
who supported abortion they obviously
weren't particularly devout catholics
but
they would support abortion and they
would justify it to themselves and to
the public by saying look
i am personally very against killing all
these babies
but politically it is a right it's a
constitutional right
you can see it right there in the
constitutional text right below the
penumbra's and right above the
emanations now you got it it's an
invisible link but you can see it it's
right there
it's right there and so therefore we
have to have legal abortion
well they're not even they're not even
pretending that anymore
now with the possible shift in the the
court
to being more conservative with the
nomination of amy coney barrett
there's a possibility i don't think it's
a very high possibility but there's a
possibility that roe v wade gets
overturned
so joe biden was asked at this town hall
the other night what will you do if it
gets overturned he said oh
well no more of this abortion should be
safe and rare
abortion you know it's constitutional
even though i oppose it
he says he would make roe v wade the law
of the land number one
we don't know exactly what she will do
although the expectation is that
she may very well move the overview
overview
over rule row and but the only thing the
only
responsible response to that would be to
pass legislation
making roe the law of the land that's
what i would do
that's what he would do he would make it
the law of the land
it was so interesting the way this woman
asked the question to he was asked right
just by constituents in the town hall
and when the woman wanted to ask about
abortion
obviously that was what the whole
question was about that's what biden's
whole answer is about
she couldn't bring herself to actually
use the term abortion
i knew whenever i was graduating high
school and entering college that i
wanted to
obtain my degree and start a career
before starting a family
having access to birth control and safe
reproductive health care was imperative
in making
that um true for me so considering the
new supreme court nomination of amy
coney barrett what are your particular
plans to protect women's reproductive
rights in the us
just as a a pure matter of semantics
abortion
is not reproductive rights it's the
opposite of reproductive rights
it does the opposite of reproduction
right there's no there's no way you can
use the term
reproduction to refer to abortion those
are those are opposite things
but she can't bring herself to say it
she can't bring herself to say it
because it's obviously such a ghastly
thing
and it's such a ghastly thing it's so
obviously
wrong that even its most ardent
supporters
can't say the name abortion
abortion what is abortion even abortion
is
a clinical term killing a baby they
can't say it
even though they support it but joe
biden is taking a pretty extreme view of
it
he's saying okay look maybe it's not a
constitutional right but
i would pass a law now passing a law for
abortion i guess is more
constitutionally legitimate than just
pretending that it's in some
clause of the constitution but does joe
biden really think this is going to help
him win pennsylvania
help him win wisconsin carolina i don't
think so
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]